come on down to Uncle sugars automall
it's the cash for clunkers extravaganza
I've got a deal for you our lots are
stacked wall to wall with these
beautiful own lines and they are priced
to move these puppies are made in
America and they are rock solid baby I
can't wait to get you behind the wheel
the cart you don't need and you can't
afford ah but wait there's more for
limited time only we got hyper-inflated
trade-in values subsidized by you the
American taxpayer my dad's body popcorn
is going on to six bills Imams nitric
salts eating to 73 seconds in prediction
padded dash weird cause they don't fit
kilibrew book that you one hundred
thirty-eight dollars awful sherbet
raining now you five hundred dollars
thousand dollars $3,000 lady oh that's
right folks I'm gonna get you 45 hundred
dollars for your training now you
courtesy a voiceless posterity how you
gonna pay for that uncle sugar we're
taking it from you yeah oh yeah New
Hampshire OPA recon shaggin wagon Oh
Chris day Oh give it to the bank bag oh
I'm gonna break it now
with the help of these guys I take some
money from this guy he don't even notice
and then it helps me sell my cars I love
this country thank you sir you are a
true patriot come on down off with
sugars optimal we're profiting at the
expense of others is the new American
Way oh just all pennsylvania avenue with
the intersection of unsound policy and
political expediency in the heart of our
nation's capitol concentrated benefits
disperse costs Oh